johnny is so Charlie yes so Charlie is
so cool good day how is everybody doing
right today I'm actually gonna do a rant
something came up recently in
conversation with my siblings and it's I
can't stop thinking about it it's a
little bit well well I tell you what
happened well there was an advert on TV
for Gwen Stefani's new fragrance
can't remember what is cool now a lamb
frankenz frankenz define
but as soon as my sister saw that antler
she automatically said I want to get
that obviously I said why why do you
want to get that and she said because
it's Gwen Stefani's fragrance does that
really make a difference we have no
argument about it well not really an
argument more of a debate we couldn't
agree on anything so I I said to her
picture this two bottles of perfume both
of them contain exactly the same liquid
and they both smell exactly the same and
they are exactly the same price but one
of them is slightly smaller than the
other one which one do you buy obviously
she said she would buy the big one
because it's better value for money and
it's just a smarter thing to do so I
asked her this same two bottles of
perfume one of them makes more than the
other one
only this time this bottle of perfume is
made by Prada and this bottle of perfume
is well it doesn't really have a make
and she said she would buy the Prada
I don't understand this at all the only
thing that has changed is the label on
the front of the perfume bottle it
really I don't understand what what what
makes you want to buy a perfume bottle
just because of the label so I said this
same kind of situation but this time the
smaller bottle of perfume smells
disgusting and it's more expensive than
this bottle of perfume and she chose the
Prada bottle it seems like the stupidest
thing in the world the label on a
product should be the last thing that
convinces you to buying it
sorry sex well why would you buy the
Prada
because it's Prada and then she went on
and said something like Charlie you have
no idea what fashion is I really really
need to see what you guys think on this
one would you buy it just because it's
Prada okay I really need your opinion on
this one guys because this is just
tearing me apart I don't understand what
it is about
that label that makes it worth buying
okay so please please please help me out
guys because I am just I don't
understand whoa whoa what is it
see you guys